Lithium is the lightest metal.
We all know that sodium is pretty light as a metal.
If you drop it onto water and forget the reaction, it floats.
The orange sodium plane. Oh, it's on your camera.
Oh, it is too.
Of course. Lithium will do the same that there are differences,
which I'll show you in a minute.
But what I wanted to see was whether we could demonstrate how much
lighter lithium was than sodium.
We'd never tried this experiment before,
but I asked Neil a technician to drop a piece of
sodium and a piece of lithium of approximately the same size.
At the same time into beakers of hexane.
Hexane is similar to gasoline or petrol. And when you drop them,
it was really striking the sodium sank like a stone
because gasoline is much less dense than water,
but lithium bopped around like a little boat. If you look carefully,
they both started bubbling because we didn't use dry hexane
and both samples of hexane contain just a little bit of water that started
reacting.
And of course that prompted Neil to want to drop the lumps
of metal into real water.
So we tried the experiment again,
dropping lithium and sodium into water.
Of course, this time, both of them floated,
but lithium is less reactive towards water than sodium.
It's a smaller atom.
The electrons are more tightly held and the reaction is slower with the
sodium. It was really quite surprising.
It went off with a real bang
And the beaker ended up in the back of the fume cupboard
And the sodium was gone and the lithium quietly bused around on the
surface of the water. And when Neil encouraged it with a flame,
we got a beautiful red color, the characteristic flame color of lithium.
The other experiment,
what we tried was burning lithium in air and comparing
it with burning lithium in nitrogen end to has the strongest
bond between any two atoms the same sort in the
periodic table.
So you need a lot of energy to break them apart because lithium is
small. It can form very tight bonds with nitrogen.
And so I read frequently that lithium will burn in nitrogen.
So I persuaded you to set fire to some lithium and it
burned really brightly in air
and then poured liquid nitrogen into beaker to fill it up with
nitrogen CAS nitrogen boils at minus 200 degrees centigrade or minus
one 96. So the gas was pretty cold in the beaker.
And then he plunged the burning lithium into the beaker.
Now here, there was a difference of opinion between me and Neil.
I thought the reaction was a great success.
Neil was a bit disappointed because the lithium just glowed
red.
But what I saw was this is not a very big piece of metal being plunged into
really cold gas.
And it kept on glowing red on and on and on.
Whereas if it had just been put out because it wasn't
reacting with nitrogen, it would have lost its color very quickly.
So I felt that it was a reasonable demonstration.
I've tried to do the same demonstration with magnesium,
which is also meant to burn in nitrogen.
I demonstrated it for 25 years to successive generations of
students and didn't work once I knew it wouldn't work,
but every time the students thought stupid professor doesn't work,
lithium is used for treating bipolar disorder,
sometimes called manic depression. This is a very distressing disease,
which is caused by imbalance of chemicals in the brain,
which causes people sometimes to be really manic and other times
so depressed that they can't get out of bed. The application,
which you use probably most often for lithium is
in batteries. This is not a new idea.
I found an old scientific American from 1967
and inside there is an advertisement here with a
picture of Edison's desk on his desk.
When he died was a large can of lithium.
This is an advertisement from a company that sells lithium or so
lithium in those days.
The reason that Edison had lithium on his desk was that he realized it
could potentially make really good batteries.
Is that the known reason or is that just what foot mineral company is
suggesting? I think that's what they're suggesting.
And since he didn't make lithium batteries, perhaps we'll never know.
So there's one final and important application of lithium,
which is in making hydrogen bonds.
Let me just remind you that an atom bomb is formed
by atoms. Usually of uranium.
There could also be plutonium splitting apart. These are called the fish bone.
A hydrogen bomb is inherently different.
The atomic energy commission and the department of defense have
conducted the important test.
Of an experimental device based on the family nuclear principle.
Bits come together. So two atoms, for example,
two deuterium.
But what is deuterium?
I was coming to that and Adam of this kind of hydrogen has the simplest nucleus
known, but hydrogen exists in two other isotopic forms, deuterium,
which has a neutron in addition to the proton and tritium,
which had two neutrons in one protein.
Atoms of hydrogen with mass to Roatan mass one
come together to form an atom of helium.
The first hydrogen bombs that were made,
and they really want to be called deuterium bombs, not hydrogen bombs involved,
liquid deuterium.
And so the bomb really looked like a small chemical factory
because they were big tanks of liquid deuterium.
And nobody could imagine carrying this on an airplane for
actually bombing.
This is the first small scale test of a hydrogen device. You have.
The reaction goes when the thermonuclear.
The breakthrough came,
when it was realized that you could use the compound of lithium
and deuterium. This is lithium deuteride L I D,
which is chemically the same as L I H. But with a heavier isotope,
what happens with that sort of bone is that you trigger it with an atom bomb
that produces a lot of neutrons and the
neutrons turn some of the lithium atoms into tritium,
hydrogen and mass three,
and then the deuterium and the tritium fuse together, giving out energy,
let him do to ride is a solid, which is stable at room temperature.
In principle, you could make lithium tritium, right? L I T,
but tritium is highly radioactive and the K's away with a half-life of
12 years.
So you have to keep on replacing your bombs so you could build
the bone without the huge containers of liquid,
and you could make something that was still pretty big,
but in principle could go in the times,
The first test of a lithium deuteride Boehm was carried out.
I think in 1954.
We feel that the report of this important test should give the failures as well
as the successes.
The test name was called castle Bravo.
The date was March one, 1954.
This photograph was taken from an airplane that 50 miles,
the width of the fireball at this time,
about three seconds after detonation was four miles.
It was really too successful.
The power of the bond was three times bigger than it had been calculated.
Amanda Shields resulted in a serious fall out situation at bikini and site.
Another eight toes down Lynn from ground zero.
The residents of the islands nearby had not been evacuated far
enough.
And several people were exposed to radiation in the
most unfortunate manner, but the principle was demonstrated,
of course the whole technology is horrific,
but it's interesting to see how lithium played the part.
But to end on a much happier note, lithium is a light metal.
Hydrogen can be used to fuel cars using
fuel cells that convert hydrogen to electricity.
So now there is a lot of research to see whether lithium
hydride or a derivative of lithium hydrate can be used to store
hydrogen in the tank of your car.
Which sarin is one of them. Unfortunately,
terrorists can get hold of it. I've got a molecule of siren here.
Not real siren, not real, sorry. No,
that would be illegal to make that I've made it of, uh, strolls and, uh,
these colored balls there.